[Music]
hi everyone my name is Artur I'm a
product manager on Android hi everybody
my name is Arun I'm in dev relations and
we're going to tell you a little bit
about android slices new api introduced
as part of android pipe so there's gonna
be a couple of things that we're gonna
cover today the first is an introduction
or we can say a reintroduction to
android slices some user experience best
practices in constructing your slices
also some more details on Search
Indexing best practices and finally
through the EAP that we've been running
over the course of the summer we've
compiled a list of important developer
gacho's for you to keep in mind for when
you start building slices when they
become available so let's start by
reintroducing slices before we get into
it I just want to remind you of some
resources that are already available for
you to start looking at we introduced
Android slices as this year's Google i/o
and so you can find more documentation
details at gqo slash slices as well you
can also look up our i/o session video
Android slices building interactive
results for Google search and that will
give you a lot of information on
constructing slices building a custom
template and building your UI for your
slice but as a quick refresher for today
slices are a new way for you to present
remote app content in Android think of
slices as embeddable app snippets which
can be easily inserted inside another
app or as part of the system slices are
meant to work across multiple possible
surfaces and the whole idea of slice is
to be able to constrain but I'll still
provide you with a lot of power and how
you express your app across multiple
contexts slices can contain a variety of
different components that you provide
including text and images but they're
also very powerful they're not just
static pieces of content they can house
real time data interactive controls and
also talk back to your app on user
interaction and so all of these
different examples that you see here are
example of slices that you can build I
mentioned that slices can be embedded
across
a multiple number of contexts and really
excited to be burying slices to search
as the first surface for you to insert
your slices so as users are typing their
query on in search on Android you'll be
able to enhance the predictions offered
by Google with live personal content
from your apps constructed through the
slices you create there are two types of
slices that you'll be able to provide in
search predictions the first are for app
name queries so if someone's searching
for your app you can accelerate them to
a canonical part in your app so for
example for YouTube maybe the desired
goal is to help get users get back to
the video that they were just watching
another use case is for any kind of
general term beyond your app name and so
in this instance users can be typing for
mobile data or data usage and the
Settings app will present them with
toggles to toggle their settings
regarding data usage so how do we build
these slices well let's start with
default slices or app name slices it's
actually very easy to build an app named
slice first you just construct a slice
as you normally would
Android Studios recent updates include
tooling to get you started
and what will happen when you create a
slices you'll generate a definition in
your manifest like this one as well as
an extension to the slice provider class
and that will provide details of how app
how the system can find your slice and
what kind of template to offer to the
system when it does to make this slice
map to your activity or to make the
slice map to your app name you have to
add the slice content URI to your main
activity and make sure to specify this
in the metadata field as pictured here
so this tells the system hey this is a
slice that I want to point to this main
activity and here is the content URI
from which you can reference that slice
the implementation details for general
terms are a little bit different so
first you actually don't provide the
same linking in an activity as you would
for an app named slice instead you're
going to use updates to the firebase app
indexing API to expose your content URI
for a specific set of keywords so using
the firebase app indexing API is you
will construct it in
taxable as you normally would that'll
have maybe a public URL it'll also have
the name for that indexable content some
very targeted keywords for users to find
that content a description and then
finally with the update to the firebase
app indexing API is you will be able to
add your content your I your slice your
I for this indexable and so when the
user is searching for the keywords that
you specified search on Android will
replace that prediction with the slice
specified by the content your eye in
this indexable finally in order for
indexable to be translated from their
public urls to their content urls
content your eyes excuse me you'll need
to override the on map intent to a URI
method in your slice provider and this
just lets you talk between these two
formats in order for your content your
eyes to be visible as a search
prediction overriding this method also
allows us to provide you the developer
with the flexibility to define whatever
your I schemas are most important to you
we're not necessarily attaching them
one-to-one great so now we know how to
build a slice and also how to expose it
to search on Android let's go into a
little bit more details on what makes a
good slice and what are some user
experience best practices to keep in
mind so the first is try to focus your
slice on one task or a set of tightly
related tasks to avoid making your slice
do too many things and make sure that's
content in the slice is coherent
regardless of where it's embedded so
keep in mind that those slices are
currently embeddable as a search
prediction for now we'd like to think
that the slices that you build should be
reusable in many other parts of the
operating system and you should consider
when building your slice for those
possibilities so the example on the left
really tries to focus a slice on being
able to consume and preview one video
the slice on the right rise to now
generalize it to a couple of other
functionality like channel selection and
so forth and really stretches the
definition and use of a slice which we
discourage you doing try to keep
interaction in a slice lightweight
highlight only the most important
fixtures features excuse me and make
sure that the actions that you're
presenting to the user are using clear
and familiar
agra fee so they can understand what
these actions represent avoid making
your slice do too many things in terms
of the actions that you have and so the
slice on the left mainly focuses on
users just listening to the content of
playlists and maybe also offers them the
ability to like certain comment the
slice on the right starts really leaning
into all the different items you can do
with all those playlist items and that's
probably functionality that that's best
served to be done within your app when
sharing your slices to different
platforms make sure you're surfacing
recognizable features and content so
that users know that they're able to
query for them and when they do query
that for them and are seeing it as a
prediction they can understand how it
might have appeared for that particular
query Arun is gonna go into a lot more
detail as to what those different cases
are but as a general principle try to
keep that the case and avoid promotional
or advertising content in your slice and
finally have your slice focus on
accelerating critical user journeys and
try to make sure that the slice helps
the user accomplish as much of that
journey in line as possible without
having to go into your app by providing
all of the necessary information and
necessary actions that the user would
need to accomplish that action and so
you can see consistently with all the
cases on the Left what's happening is
the user has all the stuff that they
need to know to understand what the
slice is for what kind of information
it's representing what kind of actions I
can do with that information like
changing the song adjusting the
temperature or adjusting the brightness
and they don't necessarily need to click
into the app to do that the slices on
the right are missing some critical
pieces of information or some critical
component as part of that user journey
and it requires users to basically it
has an additional point of friction for
users to complete the tasks that they
want to complete so that was a lot of
information on how to generally build
great slices there's gonna be a lot of
critical advice for building great
slices for search that Arun is gonna go
into thanks Arthur so here are some of
the main buckets when you think about
use cases for building slices use cases
should be familiar and hyper relevant
such as requesting a ride on a
ride-sharing app use cases should be
targeted rather than surfacing all
content in your app and finally build
slices to recall and reengagement
a reengage with content that the users
already previously seen rather than just
discover your introduced cases next
we'll see some more guidelines around
the type of content that you could
surface in slices and the data that
needs to be indexed slices should be
targeted and personalized consider the
example of a video streaming app that
shows slices when a movie that a user is
searching for is available in their app
the app could index movies liked by the
users previously or just movies curated
based on users in-app behavior do not
create an index license for all movies
in a database or even just the top 200
movies slices should give users
meaningful controls or information as an
example a ride-sharing app is building
slices so that users can request rides
to places that they are searching for in
this case create an index slices for
ride requests based on users past
history or just write request to current
popular places near the user such as
concert venues avoid creating and
indexing slices for as many places as
possible in the users geographic area
slices should give users timely
information let's say that a smart home
app is building slices so that users can
control lights in their home the app
could surface a light control slice when
the users likely in their home it's not
recommended to create an index slices
for controlling lights at any time or in
any place here are some more examples of
the type of app content index and
display in a slice a food ordering app
can easily fetch relevant real-time data
such as food price when the user
refreshes the slice similarly a news app
slice can index and display morning
digests to their readers travel and
local app slices can enable users view
their personal content such as bookings
and upcoming hot
and flight reservations let's now see
how to keep your slices fresh when a
slice is indexed the indexable object
created includes both the slice metadata
as well as a cached snapshot of the
slice and in order to ensure that the
slice that you provide the search
autocomplete is always accurate and is
not stale you should set a time to live
in your slice this time to live field is
used by the Google Search app to ensure
that stale caches are not displayed in
this code example here the time to live
for the weather slice is set to 1 our
expiration and of course if your slice
has content that is not time-sensitive
just use a time to live of infinity in
order to present fresh terror to the
user also periodically reindex your
slices in the background when content
changes and only when content changes do
not read index more than once per day to
avoid battery issues earlier Arthur
showed us how to set keywords for
general term slices using the firebase
app indexing API so what are some of the
best practices for keywords limit
keywords to 10 per slice and account for
likely permutations for example music
volume instead of media volume but don't
account for all misspellings this is
probably the most important avoid
keyword stuffing so use the minimum
number needed for needed per slice so
your app slice will be demoted in search
rankings if you use too many irrelevant
keywords that users don't end up tapping
on so what determines if your app slice
appears when the user searches for a
keyword in the Google Search app this is
the biggest question we get from
developers the most important signal is
the number of times that the user uses
your app on their device it's also
important that the user has viewed the
content previously and interacted with
it and finally in order for us to know
that the user interacted with the
content on your slice log user actions
through the app indexing API will
conclude a session today by sharing some
of the
since learnt from the slices early
access program content URI versus deep
link URLs can be confusing as our
dimension content URIs are mentioned
with a slice and start with content
colon slash slash whereas deep link
urias are associated with an indexable
and start with HTTP or HTTPS content
URIs use the package name whereas deep
link URLs follow the website or the
reverse of the package name as shown in
the example and finally when you see a
content URI
think of a slice keywords must be
included in the slice title or subtitle
else the slice will not be displayed
when the user searches for keywords this
is done in order to ensure that relevant
content is displayed to the user when
they search for something how do you
handle location slices do not provide
location to apps and therefore use the
last cache location while displaying a
size 3 index your keywords based on the
last location however also note that
indexable ZAR not instantly updated and
frequent indexing may lead to battery
issues as we mentioned before so keep in
mind the best practices for handling
location changes for your app and just
apply them to their slices as well it's
recommended to keep the slice
initialization short the oncreate slice
provider method is called for all
registered slice providers on the
applications main thread at launch time
and therefore do not perform lengthy
operations for the application startup
will be delayed if you have multiple
indexable x' as in the case of apps with
multiple slices put in all the indexable
passing all the indexable x' together as
will show on the code example and also
make sure to test your index tables if
one indexable is invalid the entire
update call will fail so here is a small
code snippet that shows it how to pass
multiple index tables to the firebase
app indexing API so now that you built
your slice how do you test it use the
slice viewer debug apk
just to view how your slice appears in
UI that's all we had for the talk for
today we would like to give a shout out
to all developers the slices early
access program thanks for attending and
have a fun rest of the session
[Applause]
[Music]